[Music]
the government wants you to use that
this is something that a lot of people
don't understand we just want to get
people to pay less tax and make more
money we're all playing the game the
only question is you're gonna play to
win are you gonna play to lose i'm gonna
borrow to buy bitcoin i'm going well
there's a dumb idea okay because
and there he is how you doing tom baby
boomer does it this is amazing
is this your first doing first time
doing a live it is it is i it's a
historic moment for this baby boomer i
love it dude i love it well thank you
for joining us in tom's got a new book
out called the win-win wealth strategy
for the youtube audience we're going to
link it up down below so you can go
check it out and it's basically all
about how you can pay as little taxes as
possible nobody likes paying the tax man
and tom's got seven amazing strategies
to help you pay as few taxes as possible
and most people are afraid of numbers
people are afraid of accountants they
don't ex they're not excited to go talk
to their accountant they don't
understand half of what those people are
saying uh they don't understand their
own balance sheet and income statement
and all and what you do a great job i
think in the book
is
you make it easy to understand yes
there's still numbers so guys there are
still numbers in there so yeah but
but there's lots of pictures uh you show
like country by country what you can do
with little check boxes so if you're a
really visual learner this is not a
really as soon as i saw a book written
by an accountant i'm like oh my gosh
this is gonna be so dry but it's it's
great it's yeah it's like so easy to
read
so many pictures and checklists and i
love your he has a stop and think
call-outs that's like takes up a third
of the page and like this is what you
need to focus on so anyway tom awesome
book thank you uh and welcome aboard
thank you it's good to be with you and
uh thanks for those comments mike my
goal in life is to make taxes fun easy
and understandable so if i can do that
in this book i i love what we did in
this book because i think it really is
simple
maybe go like by how much i have so if
i've got you know 10 000 in my account
or 100 000 or a million or 10 million
like how did what are the biggest
opportunities for people at different
stages so so the number one uh
opportunity for everybody to start their
own business that that is the number one
uh opportunity i actually run uh i like
running numbers because i'm an
accountant but it does prove things out
right and what i did was is i actually
said okay if you started a business from
home
okay how much of the cost of starting
that business
could you get the government to pay for
in reducing your taxes on your other
income
and it turns out it's over 100
so the government will literally
pay you to start a business so and and
you don't have to have any money because
you can literally
reduce your w-2 taxes take your uh you
know your your um
your w-4 reduce your taxes use the taxes
that you would otherwise have paid to
the government to start your business
and then you won't you shouldn't own
money when you
when you
fire your tax return because you will
have reduced your taxes
by more than that amount of money so it
literally the government literally pays
you to start a business so
that is the easiest thing to do it
literally takes no money at all um you i
mean
you
because you can get it from the
government right just reduce your
withholding get it from the government
or you can say well i'm gonna prefund it
okay maybe i've got five thousand
dollars i'll prefund this and i'll get
my five thousand dollars back in a
refund you know whichever way you're
doing that's that that's actually the
number one that's the easiest that's the
least expensive and it has the biggest
results i mean think about this last
couple of years
everybody's been working from home
employees didn't get to deduct their
home office and people with the business
did the big shift and so for people i
mean my audience are are mostly
entrepreneurs already or they're wanting
to be entrepreneurs so you're preaching
to the to the converted but more so from
like i want to start my own
thing as opposed to hey this is a great
tax strategy so for people who don't
know is it just a lack of information
are they talking to the wrong people are
they just afraid like why
do people not know this uh all of the
above i i do think that people think
that taxes are
what we call a zero-sum game in
economics right so the if the irs wins i
have to lose if i win that and i cheat
then that means the government loses and
that those are the only alternatives and
that's not really the way the tax law
works there are lots of things like
business where the government can win
and you can win just know that the
government will always win
you know the one thing we forget
sometimes the government's our partner
whether we like it or not we don't get
to choose that partner
right it's kind of like we don't get to
choose our parents right but we don't
get to choose the government um
hopefully we like our parents better
than the government but we don't get to
choose we don't get to choose being a
partner but we can choose how we're a
partner so we can either choose uh the
we are actually active partners with the
government in other words we're doing
things the government wants done and
when we do those things the government
gives us incentives we pay less tax if
we do things the government doesn't want
done like spending money
you know at the grocery store government
doesn't care if you spend money at the
grocery store there's no tax benefit for
that
but if you go out to eat with your
business partner you do get to deduct it
so i mean look the government's just
saying go out to eat with your business
partner don't stay home and have you
know uh grub up
and we'll give you a tax benefit if you
go out but not if you stay in
what i love about it is you're saying
hey don't make the government the enemy
this is what we have to work with and
let's find the best of you know inside
of that scenario and the bonus chapter
without maybe giving away too much but
at the very end he's got his strategies
and the bonus chapter is all about
biden versus trump and doesn't matter
and you're like it doesn't matter you
just have to make sure
you're picking what they care about to
get the tax incentive so you know going
forward
biden maybe goes through election maybe
doesn't trump maybe comes back maybe
doesn't
what are the best things now and then if
if bynum doesn't get in and let's say
trump comes back or the santos come you
know somebody else comes in
how might our tax strategy shift well so
think about what happened in 2017 right
surprise surprise we got big real estate
tax benefits i don't know who was
president oh a real estate developer
okay not surprising right we got real
real estate tax developments what's the
big push right now
big fish right now is renewable energy
well lo and behold they're huge
renewable energy tax benefits so there's
always going to be
tax benefits the government will always
incentivize things that they want you to
do okay they want you to buy an electric
car you get a 7 500 tax credit if you
buy a gas powered car you get no tax
credit
and that's a very simple example of it
right the same is true in investing
though so remember that when you invest
if you invest the way the government
wants you to invest you never have to
pay tax at all so um you know you might
make a hundred thousand dollars from
your w-2 job or from your business if
you reinvest that money into your
business real estate energy one of the
seven investments you don't have to pay
tax on that hundred thousand dollars
it's not just that you won't pay tax on
your investment money is that you won't
pay tax
on the money that you put into the
investment in the first place where are
you on buy borrow die
well in my first book tax free wealth i
actually go through a whole example of
it okay so actually there's a whole a
whole chapter on buy borrow die in my
first first book which is really
basically you buy an investment
you borrow out
any money that you need over the years
and then you die and the tax goes away
and it's it's actually a fairly simple
strategy you just have to remember that
debt's not taxable so i actually talked
about debt in chapter four of women well
strategy the government wants you to use
that this is something that a lot of
people don't understand
debt is money and money is debt so the
government wants you to borrow money and
you know right now they're raising the
interest rates to slow down how much
you're borrowing but they still want you
to borrow money and it because when you
borrow money that's new money into the
economy because the bank doesn't lend
their depositors money they lend new
money this is brand new money
and
because the money's still in the bank
right so they can't lend out your money
so they're actually lending new money
well the government wants you to do that
so the government gives you tax benefits
one of the biggest tax benefits for debt
is when when you borrow that money you
don't have to pay tax on it and
so what why not borrow i mean
when you die you know you your your your
kids can pay it off when they sell your
your real estate where they sell your
business they can pay off the debt and
they're not going to pay tax when you
die because taxes go away when you die
and and when i first discovered that
concept i was blown away like why do all
these rich entrepreneurs make no money
but then buy all these things
because they're just taking out a lot
they have no income tax usually
sometimes but it's really small they
just take out loans against the value of
their shares and the money they make
from the loans are not taxable so
they're not paying the government any
tax on it and they can go buy whatever
they want yeah sure i mean they're
they're getting uh
you know they do they put their shares
up as collateral or or you you use life
insurance i actually do a whole chapter
on insurance because you can actually
use life insurance the same way you can
borrow
you can use your life insurance as
collateral
you don't pay tax on that borrowing
actually and if you take that money for
your life insurance and you invest it
you actually get to deduct the interest
as well
so
you get like multiple tax benefits here
um just by you know understanding the
rules of the game that by the way we're
all playing the game the only question
is you're gonna play to win are you
gonna play to lose people are so afraid
of debt we've been taught that debt is
bad our parents probably told us that
don't do it and credit cards are ripping
us off
so tell us how do we rewire our mindset
around debt so it empowers us i i have a
really simple um
way to do that
um
the only reason you should have debt is
to buy an asset
right that's the reason for debt the the
purpose of debt is to buy an asset
if you don't trust if you if you're
afraid of the debts because you don't
trust the asset if you're afraid of the
debts because you don't trust the asset
people who trust the asset i mean you
you look at um like real estate
developers they have
billions of dollars of debt
well how can they get comfortable with
billions of dollars of debt well simply
because they know that the tenants are
going to pay
for
the debt so they don't have to worry
about it the tenants are going to pay
for it and they're not they know that
they know how to keep tenants in their
they know how to do their job right they
know how to get that that asset to
continue to work
i it's like me i you know do would i
ever worry about borrowing if i if i
want to borrow to expand my cpa firm
what i need to worry about no because i
know my cpa firm's always going to make
money it's made money for 30 years it's
not going to stop making money
right so i trust that asset right i
trust my business to produce the income
so it's okay if i you know if i need to
borrow in order to expand that business
if i need to borrow to reinvest i'm okay
with that because i trust the asset but
if i don't trust the asset let's say i
get let me for example let's say that
you're going well i'm going to borrow to
buy bitcoin i'm going well there's a
dumb idea okay because you should never
trust that asset because there's nothing
there to trust right i mean there's no
there there that's the challenge with
bitcoin now it may go up
it may go down we don't know but you
have no control over it so what you want
is you want an asset that you can
control
if you can control the asset then you
don't have to worry about the debt well
i think also when people are thinking
about a credit card they're not buying
assets at all they're buying right shoes
and clothes and that's bad
right so as long as you're using the
money to go buy an asset that's going to
keep going up then that and that's how
people successfully fund and grow and
the ultra wealthy keep growing right but
but look at i mean we have a really good
example of an example where somebody's
not so
comfortable borrowing money because uh
because their asset went down this is uh
elon musk right he's not so comfortable
buying twitter because the stock market
came way down and he doesn't have the
collateral that he had before in tesla
and so now he's worried about okay do i
really want that debt to buy twitter
right i think that's my personal opinion
i think that's what's really going on
here is he's going do i really you know
now the stock market has come way down i
mean tesla is not 2 000 anymore it's 750
right now that stock market's coming way
down do i really want that debt do i
really trust that twit you know i said
originally i don't care about i don't
care about whether twitter makes money
but
man maybe i do now
right so so it's not just it's not just
the average person rich people have the
same problem you have to make sure this
is where
i think that was his big mistake frankly
and i i'm a big fan of elon musk but i
think that was his big mistake because i
think he you know when he said i don't
care if it makes money
okay i think if he were confident that
it were going to make mon it was going
to make money it wouldn't have mattered
he i i think he'd be going through the
deal i i don't think this would be an
issue i just think he's not confident
that that asset is going to pay for the
liability
so back to your earlier point if you're
going to take a debt to loan to buy
something that's going to go up that
you're confident in then you do it
otherwise you don't right
at the highest level of buying a you
know billion dollar company plus or at
the lowest level
100 bucks to buy whatever asset you
think is going to go up i love it
so
you know that's the so the advice for
the pure somebody at the very beginning
is go start a business
right there's so many deductions that
you can have to start a business if
somebody's already had some success if
they have a hundred thousand if they
have a million dollars maybe not like
elon musk level but they have they have
some money what's the biggest
opportunity that those people are
missing out on
i choose one of the other
so i i'd actually look at so whether
it's real estate
energy agriculture
technology i'd be looking at one of the
other seven investments and go okay
which one's interesting to me which one
what do i care about um some people care
about real estate some people say wow
that would be really interesting to do
real estate
somebody will go you know what i'd
really like to go
start a i'd like to do a a winery i'd
like to build i'd like to have a
vineyard right so they go do agriculture
or somebody else might go you know what
i want to go get into new technology so
i'm going to go into in into that it
doesn't matter they all have
similar tax benefits
um they all have great tax benefits
energy renewable energy right now
probably the greatest tax benefit out
there is renewable energy when you put
it on your own business property okay
that's a terrific tax benefit okay so
that
what what that means is i just need to
choose this is why i did a survey right
this is why there are seven investments
i'm going look not everybody likes all
seven i'm never gonna have a farm i'm
not a farmer it's not in me okay
um
i'm just not but
am i interested in energy i've always
been interested in energy i'm putting
solar right now on my office building
my return on investment i estimate to be
about 22 percent because the
government's paying so much of that
upfront cost
so 25 return i'll take that right on
something that has literally no risk it
is always going to be sunny in arizona
300 days a year we are not worried about
that so we're going to have that return
on a consistent basis i can control that
return so um i would i would just pick
one i'd read the book i'd read all the
chapters and say okay which one's
interesting to me and that's the one i
would choose and that's when i would
learn more about
and is that then a conversation they
take to their cpa and say hey like let's
go learn about this
uh maybe their cpa i will tell you their
cpa probably doesn't know
know how to invest i mean very few cpas
actually are investors that that's a
problem actually in my my profession um
i would i would go to other educators
you know if i were in if i were wanting
to learn about multi-family real estate
i'd go to a multi-family real estate
educator like brad sumrock for example
right or ken mcelroy if i were if i were
looking at um a stock investing i go to
you know as a stock trainer like stephen
brooks or andy tanner or john carter you
know one of these guys that's really
good trainer on it i'd go to the i go to
the specialist i go to the professionals
what you want to go to your cpa with is
once you decide i want to do this go to
your cpa and say okay now how do i do
this most tax effectively
that's that's what your cpa is for is
now how do i put this all together i
decided i want to do real estate or i
decided i want to do energy i decided i
want to do agriculture how do i set this
up so that i get all the tax benefits
build the most amount of wealth and take
the least amount of risk
i know robert kiyosaki wrote the forward
for your book which is fantastic amazing
but what uh what do we go to robert
kiyosaki for
uh general education so uh all there is
so i'm a rich dad advisor and that's
robert's company uh so i advise uh the
rich dad company um uh ken mcelroy is
the real estate guy um uh john mcgregor
is the uh stock guy uh garrett sutton is
the legal guy so so there's that there
are specialists you know at the richtek
company rich dad i what i go to rich dad
for you really want to learn basics of
investing you go play as gain cash flow
that is where you learn the basics
investing that's how you get comfortable
with borrowing money because you
practice borrowing you practice going
bankrupt you practice getting the
feeling for oh how do i do this and you
practice over and over again then you go
to do it in real life right like you
would with a if you were stock trading
you'd go paper trade for a year before
you actually made an actual trade well
why not play a game and practice real
estate investing before you actually go
do real estate investing i mean so that
that's really uh rich dad that that gain
cash flow there are cash flow clubs all
over the world they have like 3 500 cash
flow clubs and so there's one near you
and i i think it's a i think it's a
fabulous game it's a it has both an
income statement a balance sheet and a
statement of cash flow and an auditor so
i love it this is it's a great great
game
i played that game 20 years ago
and it's still just as relevant and i
remember i forget how much it cost and i
was like why is this game so expensive
20 years ago and then i played it it's
like ah now i get it
because there's so many great lessons
you take as an entrepreneur to be able
to not even as a not sure but you know
like that's one of the pushes hey start
your own business you can you can save a
lot of money doing it cool for for
people watching obviously go buy the
book youtube we're going to link it up
down below it's called the win win
wealth strategy go check it out what
what do you hope is the next
single action that people take after
they read the book i would hope that
they choose a category
uh something that they really would be
interested in doing that the government
once done and then i would hope they
would find a really good cpa to help
them set it up uh we we do have a full
disclosure i run a network of 60 cpa
firms around the country so this is our
business is training cpas to do this
and if you need help you go to
wealthability.com and we'll help you if
you want your cpa to get help we'll help
them too so we don't care we're just
happy to we just wanna we just want to
get people to pay less tax and make more
money that's all but what's the single
most important question people should
ask their cpa ah
a single most important question i think
is what questions would you like to ask
me
and then if they stumble then it's the
wrong cpa
exactly because it's like if you go to a
doctor
you don't expect to be asking all the
questions you expect the doctor to be
asking all the questions they've got to
do the diagnosis the same thing with the
cpa cpa needs to be doing the diagnosis
most important skill set of an advisor
is to ask good questions if they can't
ask you good questions you need a new
cpa
i like that what an answer well guys the
book is called the win-win wealth
strategy we'll link it up youtube down
in the description go check it out tom
thank you for the love the energy
showing up for your first live and best
of luck with the book
thanks evan
to see my sit-down with tony robbins
personal financial advisor check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there there's this myth the
market goes up the market goes down
that's not really true so how do i know
who the person is to help me build my
wealth plan like how do i identify that
person